Je pense qu'en expérimentant ces futurs robotiques possibles,
on finit par en apprendre plus sur nous-mêmes
que juste sur les robots.
J'ai appris, ce jour-là,
que j'avais des attentes plutôt élevées pour ce petit gars.
Il ne devait pas seulement pouvoir évoluer dans l'espace physique,
mais aussi dans mon espace social –
il en fait partie : c'est un robot personnel.
Pourquoi ne me comprend-il pas?
Mon hôte m'a expliqué :
« Un robot essaie d'aller d'un point A vers un point B,
tu étais un obstacle sur son chemin,
il a donc dû reprogrammer son parcours,
réfléchir où aller
et ensuite s'y rendre autrement »,
ce qui n'était pas une façon de faire très efficace.
Si ce robot avait réalisé que j'étais une personne, pas une chaise,
que j'étais prête à m'écarter de son chemin,
où qu'il ait cherché à aller,
il aurait plus efficacement
rempli sa mission,
s'il avait détecté que j'étais humaine
et que mes potentialités sont différentes des chaises et des murs.
On pense souvent que ces robots viennent d'une autre planète,
du futur, de la science-fiction.
Et même si c'était vrai,
j'aimerais soutenir qu'aujourd'hui, les robots existent,
ils vivent et travaillent parmi nous.
Voici deux robots qui vivent chez moi.
Ils passent l'aspirateur et coupent l'herbe,
tous les jours,
c'est plus que ce que je ferais, si j'avais le temps.
Ils le font aussi probablement mieux que moi.
Celui-ci s'occupe de mon chat.
Chaque fois qu'il utilise son bac, il le nettoie,
ce que je ne suis pas prête à faire,
même si ça améliore beaucoup sa vie et la mienne.
Comme on appelle ces robots des produits –
« robot aspirateur », « robot tondeuse à gazon »,
« robot bac à litière » -
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres robots cachés sous nos yeux,
ils sont juste devenus tellement utiles
et banals
qu'on les appelle par exemple « lave-vaisselle ».
Ils ont de nouveaux noms.
On ne les appelle plus « robots »
parce qu'ils ont une raison d'être dans nos vies.
De même, un thermostat –
je sais que mes amis roboticiens
seront sans doute gênés que j'y voie un robot,
mais il a un but.
Son but est de faire en sorte que ma maison soit à 19 degrés,
il sent ce qui l'entoure.
Quand il fait un peu froid,
il crée un programme et agit sur l'univers physique.
C'est de la robotique.
Même s'il ne ressemble pas à Rosie, le robot des Jetson,
il accomplit quelque chose qui est très utile dans ma vie.
Donc je n'ai plus besoin
d'augmenter ou de baisser la température moi-même.
Les robots vivent et travaillent parmi nous aujourd'hui,
mais ils ne font pas que vivre parmi nous :
vous êtes probablement vous aussi un opérateur de robot.
Quand vous conduisez,
c'est comme si vous pilotiez un engin.
Vous allez vous aussi d'un point A à un point B,
mais vous avez sûrement une direction assistée,
un système automatique de freins,
peut-être une boîte automatique et même un régulateur de vitesse.
Bien que votre voiture ne soit pas complètement autonome,
elle l'est quand même un peu
et c'est tellement utile,
on peut conduire plus sûrement,
on a juste l'impression que ça disparaît à l'usage, pas vrai ?
Donc, en conduisant sa voiture,
c'est juste comme aller d'un endroit à un autre.
On n'a pas l'impression que c'est si compliqué à utiliser,
toutes ces commandes.
C'était si long d'apprendre à conduire
qu'elles deviennent des extensions de nous-mêmes.
Quand on gare sa voiture dans une place étroite,
on sait où sont les côtés.
Mais quand on loue une voiture, qu'on n'a peut-être jamais conduite,
on prend du temps à s'habituer à notre nouveau corps robotique.
C'est aussi vrai pour les gens qui utilisent d'autres types de robots
et je voudrais vous partager quelques expériences.
À propos du travail à distance.
A Willow Garage, mon collègue Dallas
ressemblait à ça.
Il travaillait pour notre entreprise californienne, de chez lui dans l'Indiana.
C'était une voix au micro pendant la plupart de nos réunions,
et ça marchait plutôt bien, sauf
quand on avait un débat animé, qu'on n'était pas d'accord avec lui,
on pouvait juste raccrocher.
(Rires)
Ensuite on pouvait avoir une autre réunion
et prendre les décisions dans le couloir,
quand il n'était plus là.
Ce n'était pas super pour lui.
Comme on est fabricants de robots,
on avait quelques morceaux en trop qui traînaient,
alors Dallas et son ami Curt ont fabriqué ça :
une sorte de Skype fixé sur un bâton équipé de roues,
qui ressemble à un jouet geek idiot,
mais, en vrai, c'est un des outils les plus puissants
que j'aie jamais vus pour travailler à distance.
Maintenant, si je ne réponds pas à la question de Dallas par mail,
il peut littéralement rouler vers mon bureau,
bloquer ma porte et me reposer la question –
(Rires)
jusqu'à ce que je réponde.
Je ne vais pas le désactiver, ce serait impoli.
Ce robot ne lui sert pas que pour les discussions à deux,
mais aussi à être visible à la réunion des employés.
Se caler sur une chaise,
montrer aux gens que vous êtes là, engagé dans votre projet,
c'est important
et ça peut booster le travail à distance.
On a pu le voir pendant des mois, puis des années,
pas que dans notre entreprise, ailleurs aussi.
Ce qui peut arriver de mieux avec un robot,
c'est de sentir ne faire qu'un avec lui.
C'est juste vous, votre corps
et les gens commencent à lui reconnaître une existence propre.
Donc, quand il y aura une réunion debout,
les gens se placeront autour de lui
comme ils l'auraient fait si vous étiez là.
C'est génial, jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait des bugs.
La première fois qu'ils voient ces robots,
les gens cherchent les composants : « Il doit y avoir une caméra par ici »,
ils tapotent votre tête :
« Tu parles trop bas, je vais augmenter ton volume. »
C'est comme si un collègue venait chez vous et disait :
« Tu parles trop bas, je vais monter le son de ta tête. »
C'est gênant et incorrect,
on a donc dû créer de nouvelles normes sociales
pour utiliser ces systèmes.
De même, dès qu'on commence à s'y sentir comme dans son propre corps,
on se met à remarquer des choses comme : « Mon robot est trop petit. »
Si Dallas me parlait – il fait 1 mètre 80 –
qu'on emmenait son robot à des cocktails et à des soirées,
où on va,
et que le robot fait 1 mètre 50, ce qui est proche de ma taille,
Dallas me dirait :
« Les gens ne me regardent pas vraiment.
J'ai l'impression de ne voir qu'une mer d'épaules –
il me faut un robot plus grand. »
Je lui ai répondu :
« Euh, non.
Tu vas te sentir à ma place aujourd'hui.
Tu vas voir ce que ça fait d'être au niveau de l'épaule des gens. »
Cette expérience lui a fait ressentir beaucoup d'empathie,
c'était plutôt formidable.
Quand il venait lui-même me voir,
il ne restait plus debout, devant moi, à me parler,
il s'asseyait et me parlait à mon niveau,
c'était très touchant.
On a donc décidé d'étudier ce phénomène en laboratoire,
de voir ce que des différences, comme la taille d'un robot, changent.
La moitié de notre échantillon a utilisé un petit robot,
l'autre moitié, un grand robot.
On a découvert que la même personne,
avec exactement le même physique et qui dit exactement la même chose,
est plus convaincante et paraît plus crédible
avec la grande version du robot.
Ce n'est pas rationnel,
d'où le recours à la psychologie.
En fait, Cliff Nass dirait
qu'il nous faut interagir avec ces nouvelles technologies,
malgré le fait que nous ayons de très vieux cerveaux.
La psychologie humaine n'évolue pas aussi vite que la tech,
on se met tout le temps à jour,
pour chercher du sens dans un monde
où les machines autonomes nous entourent.
Normalement ce sont les gens qui parlent, pas les machines.
Et donc on associe beaucoup de choses comme la taille d'une machine –
pas de la personne –
à celui qui utilise le système.
Je pense que c'est très important
quand on réfléchit à la robotique.
Ce n'est pas tant réinventer l'humain,
mais plutôt découvrir comment étendre ses possibilités.
On en vient à utiliser les robots d'une façon très surprenante.
Ces robots ne peuvent pas jouer au billard car ils n'ont pas de bras,
mais ils peuvent interpeller les joueurs,
ce qui peut beaucoup contribuer à créer un esprit d'équipe,
c'est assez génial.
Les gens qui arrivent très bien à utiliser les robots
inventent même de nouveaux jeux,
comme le football robotique en pleine nuit,
renversant les poubelles.
Tout le monde n'y arrive pas.
Beaucoup de gens ont du mal à utiliser les robots.
Cet homme s'est connecté à un robot,
dont l'œil était tourné à 90 degrés sur la gauche.
Il ne le savait pas
et il s'est mis à se cogner partout au bureau,
à foncer dans les gens, qui devenaient très gênés.
Il en riait – son volume était bien trop fort.
Cet homme me disait sur l'image :
« Il faut un bouton pour couper le son. »
En fait, il voulait dire qu'on ne veut pas de robots aussi turbulents.
En tant que fabricants de robots,
on a intégré au système des obstacles à éviter.
Il a reçu un petit laser pour détecter les obstacles.
Si l'opérateur du robot essaie de le faire aller dans une chaise,
ça ne marchera pas : le robot en fera juste le tour,
ce qui est une meilleure idée.
Grâce à ce programme, les gens heurtaient moins d'obstacles,
mais quelques personnes
mettaient plus de temps à finir la classe d'obstacles,
on a voulu savoir pourquoi.
Il s'est avéré qu'il y a un élément important chez l'humain :
le locus de contrôle, rattaché à la personnalité.
Les gens dotés d'un fort locus interne de contrôle
ont besoin de maîtriser leur propre destin –
ils détestent laisser le contrôle à un système autonome.
Ils se battent contre ce système autonome :
« Si je veux heurter cette chaise, je le ferai. »
Ils n'apprécient pas d'avoir une aide programmée,
c'est une chose importante à savoir
alors qu'on construit des voitures de plus en plus autonomes, non ?
Comment réagiront des gens différents face à cette perte de contrôle ?
Ce sera différent selon les caractéristiques de chacun.
On ne peut pas traiter les humains comme s'ils étaient semblables.
On diffère par notre personnalité, notre culture,
parfois même, en fonction de notre état émotionnel.
Pour concevoir des systèmes
d'interactions entre humains et robots,
on doit prendre en compte les caractéristiques humaines,
pas que celles de la technologie.
Avec le sens du contrôle vient le sens des responsabilités.
Si vous pilotiez un robot utilisant un de ces systèmes,
voilà ce à quoi l'interface ressemblerait.
C'est un peu comme dans un jeu vidéo :
c'est bien, car c'est très familier pour les gens.
Mais le mauvais côté,
c'est que les gens se croient dans un jeu vidéo.
Des enfants sont venus jouer avec le système à Stanford,
conduire un robot dans nos bureaux à Menlo Park
et ils se sont mis à dire, par exemple :
« 10 points si tu cognes le type là-bas, 20 points pour l'autre ».
Ils poursuivaient les gens dans le hall.
(Rires)
Je leur ai dit : « Ce sont de vrais gens
qui vont vraiment saigner et avoir mal si vous les cognez. »
Ils répondaient : « OK, compris. »
Mais cinq minutes plus tard, c'était :
« 20 points pour le type là-bas, il a l'air d'avoir besoin d'être cogné. »
Un peu comme dans La Stratégie Ender.
Il y a un monde réel de l'autre côté,
je pense que c'est notre responsabilité, en créant ces interfaces,
d'aider à se souvenir
que nos actions ont des conséquences réelles,
à avoir le sens des responsabilités
quand on utilise ces systèmes de plus en plus autonomes.
Voici de très bons exemples
d'expérimentations d'un futur robotique possible.
Je pense que c'est formidable de pouvoir étendre ses possibilités,
d'apprendre de notre façon de le faire,
dans ces machines,
tout en étant capable d'exprimer son humanité
et sa personnalité.
Et on a de l'empathie pour autrui
quelle que soit sa taille, sa vitesse
et parfois même son handicap,
c'est génial.
On a aussi de l'empathie pour les robots eux-mêmes.
Voici un de mes robots préférés.
C'est le Tweenbot.
Ce petit gars a un fanion qui dit :
« J'essaie d'aller à ce croisement à Manhattan »,
il est mignon, il roule, et c'est tout.
Il ne sait pas comment créer une carte, ni voir le monde :
il demande de l'aide.
Ce qui est bien chez les gens,
c'est qu'il a pu compter sur la gentillesse d'étrangers.
Il a bien traversé le parc jusqu'à l'autre côté de Manhattan –
ce qui est génial –
juste parce que les gens le mettaient dans la bonne direction.
(Rires)
Et c'est génial, non ?
On cherche à construire ce monde mixte humain et robotique
dans lequel on peut coexister et travailler, tous ensemble.
Pas besoin d'être complètement autonome et de tout faire tout seul.
On fait les choses ensemble.
Et pour y arriver,
on a besoin de l'aide des artistes et designers,
dirigeants politiques, juristes,
psychologues, sociologues, anthropologues, etc.
On a besoin de plus de points de vue
si on veut faire ce que Stuart Card nous conseille :
inventer le futur dans lequel on veut vraiment vivre.
Je pense qu'on peut continuer à expérimenter
différents futurs robotiques ensemble,
et, ce faisant, on finira par en apprendre beaucoup plus sur nous-mêmes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)